DONE, AMBASSADOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW, NATO
SECRETARY-GENERAL JENS
STOLTENBERG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
OVERNIGHT WE SAW THE RUSSIANS
TAKE CONTROL OF ZAPORIZHZHIA
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT.
IT WAS SET ON FIRE IN AN ATTACK
OVERNIGHT.
WE NEVER HAVE SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, EVER, A NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT UNDER ATTACK.
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN KYIV CALLS
IT A WAR CRIME.
IT IS A CLEAR ESCALATION IN THE
RUSSIAN BEHAVIOR.
DOES THAT NECESSITATE AN
ESCALATION IN THE NATO RESPONSE?
>> WELL, WHAT YOU SAW LAST NIGHT
WAS RECKLESS ACTION OF WAR IN
AND AROUND A NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT.
AND THIS DEMONSTRATES THE DANGER
OF THIS WAR.
AND UNDERLINES THE IMPORTANCE OF
PUTIN ENDING THIS WAR,
WITHDRAWING ALL THE FORCES, AND
ENGAGING IN EFFORTS TO FIND A
POLITICAL DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION.
WAR -- WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
RUSSIA IS SHELLING RESIDENTIAL
AREAS, KILLING CIVILIANS AND NOW
ALSO THE DANGERS RELATED TO A
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT.
>> WE SAW THE VIDEO, WE SAW THE
VIDEO JUST THIS MORNING RELEASED
BY THE UKRAINIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER OF A RESIDENTIAL
APARTMENT COMPLEX, I THINK WE
CAN SHOW IT TO YOU RIGHT NOW, IN
B ORODYANKO, CIVILIANS ARE BEING
KILLED HERE, DOES IT SEEM TO YOU
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS BEING
DETERRED IN ANY WAY?
>> THIS IS PRESIDENT PUTIN'S
WAR.
HE PLANNED IT AND HE'S NOW
WAGING THE WAR AGAINST INNOCENT
PEOPLE IN UKRAINE, VIOLATING
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
WE WARNED HIM THAT IF HE ONCE
AGAIN INVADED UKRAINE, WE WOULD
IMPOSE MORE SEVERE SANCTIONS THE
WORLD EVER HAS SEEN.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
WE'RE IMPOSING THOSE COSTS.
OUR SOURCES STEPPING UP THEIR
SUPPORT TO UKRAINE, MILITARY
SUPPORT, INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT,
AND WE RALLIED THE WHOLE WORLD,
SAW THAT IN THE U.N., TO CONDEMN
AND CALL RUSSIA TO STOP THE WAR,
TO WITHDRAW TROOPS AND ENGAGE IN
DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS.
>> YOU SAID NO NATO TROOPS.
YOU SAID NO NATO PLANES IN
UKRAINIAN AIR SPACE.
WHEN YOU SEE RESIDENTIAL
APARTMENT COMPLEXES LIKE THAT
ABLAZE, OR IN RUBBLE, AS A HUMAN
BEING, IS THERE ANY SENSE OF
REMORSE THAT YOU CAN'T DO MORE?
>> WHAT WE SEE IS HEINOUS.
IT IS A BRUTALITY.
IT IS KILLING OF CIVILIANS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE THE SECOND
WORLD WAR IN EUROPE.
AND I THINK A LOT OF COURAGE OF
THE UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCE, THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, THEY REALLY
INSPIRED THE WHOLE WORLD TO STEP
UP AND NATO ALLIES ARE PROVIDING
MORE SUPPORT, MILITARY SUPPORT,
BUT ALSO HUMANITARIAN, INCLUDING
CALLING ON TALKS TO PROVIDE
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS CONFLICT
DOESN'T SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL,
AND GOES BEYOND UKRAINE.
AND FULL FLEDGED WAR IN EUROPE,
INVOLVING MANY MORE COUNTRIES.
EUROPE, RUSSIA, AGAINST NATO.
THAT WILL CAUSE EVEN MORE
SUFFERING, EVEN MORE DEATH, EVEN
MORE CIVILIAN KILLED.
SO THEREFORE WE PROVIDE SUPPORT,
WE ARE ARE STEPPING UP THE
SUPPORT, BUT WE ALSO MADE IT
CLEAR WE ARE NOT PART OF THE
CONFLICT, WE ARE THE DEFENSIVE
LINES AND WE WILL NOT MOVE NATO
TROOPS OR NATO AIR FORCES INTO
UKRAINE.
>> ARE YOU SEEING ANY SIGN YOU
TALK ABOUT NATO MEMBERS HERE,
OBVIOUSLY THE BALTIC STATES
COULD BE SEEN AS AN AREA OF
SPECIFIC CONCERN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE THEY'RE UNDER GREATER
THREAT THIS MORNING?
>> WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED THE MILITARY PRESENCE
OF NATO FORCES IN EASTERN PART
OF THE ALLIANCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS NO ROOM FOR
MISCALCULATION OR
MISUNDERSTANDING IN MOSCOW ABOUT
NATO'S READINESS TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND ALL ALLIES AS LONG AS WE
STANT TOGETHER, ONE FOR ALL, ALL
FOR ONE, THEN ALL ALLIES ARE
SAFE BECAUSE WE ARE THE
STRONGEST ALLIANCE IN HISTORY,
50% OF THE WORLD'S MILITARY
MIGHT, AND OUR COMMITMENT TO OUR
SECURITY GUARANTEES, ARTICLE 5
OF THE WASHINGTON TREATY IS IRON
CLAD.
AND WE DEMONSTRATE THAT BY
HAVING MORE U.S. TROOPS,
EUROPEAN TROOPS, CANADIAN
TROOPS, AND EASTERN PART OF THE
ALLIANCE.
SO THAT'S TO PREVENT ANY ATTACK
AGAINST ANY NATO ALLY.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
YOU SAY ALL ALLIES ARE SAFE.
BUT IF A MAN WHO IS WILLING TO
INVADE THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
ATTACK A NUCLEAR POWER PLANT
THERE OVERNIGHT, HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT THEY'RE ALL SAFE?
WHAT WOULD STOP HIM IF HE'S
WILLING TO FIRE ON A NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT, WOULDN'T HE
THEORETICALLY BE WILLING TO
MAYBE FIRE ON A NATO NATION?
>> WE HAVE TO MINIMIZE THAT RISK
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE ARE
DOING WHAT WE ARE DOING FOR MORE
THAN SEVEN YEARS, ALSO DOING THE
MOST DIFFICULT TIMES DURING THE
COLD WAR.
NATO WAS ABLE TO PRESERVE PEACE,
PREVENT AN ATTACK.
AND THE MAIN PURPOSE OF NATO IS
TO PRESERVE PEACE BY SENDING A
VERY CLEAR MESSAGE OF DETERRENCE
TO ANY POTENTIAL ADVERSARY.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO ALSO TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN, TO MOSCOW
TODAY.
AND IF ANYTHING THIS CRISIS
DEMONSTRATES THE IMPORTANCE OF
NORTH AMERICA, EUROPE STANDING
TOGETHER, WE SEE MORE U.S.
FORCES IN EUROPE, WE SEE ALSO
THE EUROPEAN ALLIES AND CANADA
ARE STEPPING UP, GERMANY JUST
ANNOUNCED 2% OF SPENDING, 2% OF
GDP, 100 BILLION EXTRA FOR
DEFENSE AND GERMANY HAS DOUBLED
THEIR PRESENCE IN LITHUANIA.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY
CONVINCING AND STRONG MESSAGE TO
MOSCOW ABOUT THE COMMITMENT TO
ALL NATO ALLIES TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND EACH OTHER AND THIS
WORKED DURING THE COLD WAR AND
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT WORKS
ALSO TODAY.
>> ONE OF THE IRONIES IS NATO
HAS NEVER BEEN MORE UNIFIED IT
SEEMS THAN IT IS NOW.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS GETTING THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE MIGHT HAVE
WANTED.
ANTONY BLINKEN JUST IN A NATO
MEETING IN BRUSSELS.
WHAT IS NEXT FOR NATO,
SECRETARY-GENERAL?
>> WE WILL MONITOR THE SITUATION
VERY CLOSELY.
WE'RE STEPPING UP SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE.
WE ARE INCREASING THE PRESENCE
IN THE EASTERN PART OF THE
ALLIANCE, AND THEN, OF COURSE,
WE WILL CONTINUE TO CALL ON
RUSSIA TO ENGAGE IN DIPLOMATIC
EFFORTS TO FIND A POLITICAL
SOLUTION TO THIS CONFLICT.
AND ON THE 16th OF MARCH, NATO
DEFENSE MINISTERS WILL MEET, AND
THEY WILL HAVE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE LONG-TERM CONSEQUENCES, WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN FOR NATO IN THE
LONG-TERM, THE RELATIONSHIP, THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA, BUT
ALSO LONG-TERM ADJUSTMENTS TO
OUR PRESENCE POSTURE, MILITARY
POSTURE, ESPECIALLY EASTERN PART
OF THE ALLIANCE.